after the incredible success of bird box
Netflix has devised a sequel set halfway
across the Earth where are we Barcelona
that's right the city where such horror
films as wreck the orphanage and Vicky
Christina Barcelona are set provides the
backdrop for this sequel about monsters
who want to be seen so basically my
ex-girlfriend now come along with me as
we take a deep dive into the movie its
connection to the original and why I'm
never commuting to work
oh sounds like somebody's got a case of
the Mundus
meet Sebastian an engineer hoping to
save the world from climate change and
while he's not Moonlighting as Greta
thundberg he's raising his daughter Anna
the film actually starts nine months
after the world has gone to Hell after
an event simply known as the problem
mysterious entities never given a name
in the book or film have taken over
causing anyone who looks at them to
unalive themselves and if you've seen
the original you know how these entities
operate they can't physically harm you
but instead cause people to experience
intense hallucinations culminating in
suicidal Behavior
that's got to hurt I don't care where
you're from now there are some people
who instead of dying turn into these
crazy zealots hell-bent on making others
open their eyes although never
specifically stated what causes some to
turn this way it's heavily implied this
may happen to individuals who are
mentally ill or have experienced
tremendous trauma and as we follow
Sebastian in this point will be made
ever more clear Sebastian's that cool
dad even though he's risking their lives
he wants his daughter to enjoy some
roller skating for whatever reason these
entities can't enter buildings that are
covered up but the same can't be said
for blind thieves who scavenge the
barcelonian city for scraps kind of like
me drunkenly stumbling down last rhombus
at 3am for Shawarma Sebastian and Anna
come across a group of survivors who
have creatively set up this shopping
cart and rope system so they can easily
find their way back to a giant bus
terminal they've called home normally
these survivors would be distrusting but
Sebastian being an engineer says he
knows the location of a generator
electricity would be considered a luxury
thus they take Sebastian in but you may
notice Anna isn't with him this brings
us to the first big twist of the movie
Sebastian is known as what's called a
Seer one of those zealots I mentioned
earlier whose goal is to get others to
see the entities these entities
manipulate those around them to achieve
this goal Sebastian doesn't know where
any of these generators are he just
wants to infiltrate this group and do
whatever it takes to kill them but in
Sebastian's mind he isn't killing them
he's saving them while the survivors are
sleeping he steals the keys to their bus
and crashes it outside the building
leaving everyone in its wreckage prey to
the entities with each death he sees a
bright light leave their body almost as
if it's their souls going up to heaven
foreign
but there's one Survivor a man who
stabbed his eyes out by the name of
Lazaro Sebastian doesn't kill him the
entities aren't interested in those who
can't see earlier when lazara recounts
the story of losing his eyesight he said
the Sears that came for him lost
interest in him after he lost his sight
and when Sebastian had the opportunity
to kill the blind thieves Anna tells him
not to do it for whatever reason those
who are blind are of no interest to the
entities in Sebastian's mind he's doing
God's work equating himself to a
Shepherd leading lost souls to God in
fact there are several nods to Shepherd
imagery and wolf in sheep's clothing
throughout the film now this voice
telling him to do this manifests in the
form of his dead daughter Anna is but a
figment of his imagination created from
trauma that happened roughly two months
ago Sebastian and Anna had been hiding
in an apartment complex but unbeknownst
to them were tracked by a group of seers
who saw the light from Sebastian's cake
he scavenged for Anna's birthday this is
important because it ties into his guilt
if he had never lit that candle perhaps
they never would have been found and
Anna would be alive today this group of
Sears is led by a fanatic priest who
believes the entities are ushering in an
age of prophets and miracles he wants
Anna and Sebastian to see the beauty of
God and to open their eyes but when Anna
is subjected to this quote-unquote
beauty she plummets to her death
Sebastian on the other hand is one of
those lucky few who's turned into a Seer
now at the end of the movie we get a
little more insight as to why some
people turn into Sears and others do not
a doctor at the mountain stronghold of
Mount jewick a place we'll see later on
in the film theorizes that extreme forms
of stress can cause changes in the DNA
if this theory is correct we can assume
Sebastian witnessing his own daughter
unalive herself caused him to change
into a Seer these entities also appear
to others in various forms whether it be
the sound of a loved one like how Claire
hears her brother Jack Lillian her lover
or Anna for Sebastian but how do these
entities know this how do they take on
these aspects to better manipulate us
there is one theory proposed by Octavio
a pizza delivery man with a degree in
physics from the University of Mexico he
believes the entities are some sort of
quantum being that constantly are
changing to take on the forms of our
greatest fears grief and pain they can
come in the form of aliens to some
demons to others and in Sebastian's case
angels and God and just a quick reminder
before we move on to close your eyes and
hit that like And subscribe button every
little bit helps me stock up for the
apocalypse before Sebastian became a
Seer you could tell he was a religious
man he has a cross in his car his
daughter attends a Catholic school and
he gives Anna a special necklace for her
first communion one of a Seraph a Seraph
is a six-winged angel which Sebastian
calls the most beautiful of all so the
entities use Sebastian's already
pre-established Notions of God and
angels to fuel his motivation for
killing others he sees the bright
Angelic lights come out of those he
kills so he truly believes he's doing
God's work but not everyone who is a
Seer sees it that way he'll find this
guy who describes the entities as aliens
who have traveled millions of miles to
get here and take us to the Stars
after culling the survivors at the bus
terminal Sebastian finds another group
of survivors led by Dr Claire Barnes an
English psychologist who ironically was
on a book tour in Spain for her book age
of Madness how to survive the modern
world it's here we meet a lone German
girl by the name of Sophia and thanks to
Sebastian knowing German from his work
in the turbine fields we learned that
before she lost contact with her mother
a radio broadcast told of a refuge at
Mount jewick Castle a fortified
stronghold only accessible via Gondola
now this crew doesn't know that
Sebastian can freely see without being
driven to Suicide giving him ample
opportunity to appease the ghost of Anna
who says that only by killing them can
Sebastian be reunited with her
and so that night Sebastian phrase part
of the Rope used to leash their dogs
causing absolute pandemonium on their
travels to the gondola Rafa upon hearing
the Yelp from his dog is tricked into
taking his blindfold off and he gets
himself a 1 way ticket to heaven or at
least that's what Sebastian thinks while
hiding in a nearby apartment Claire
tells Sebastian this story about her
brother and how grief affected her
couldn't even admit to myself that he
was dead grief can break you like that
you know it's grief which isn't allowing
Sebastian to admit to himself that Anna
is dead if he's going to overcome this
control over him he'll need to come to
that realization and this change occurs
with the death of Octavio while scouting
the apartment for medicine Sebastian
leaves the window open and calls in
Octavio telling him it's safe to take
off his blindfold allowing The Entity to
drive Octavio to Madness but when he
dies Sebastian doesn't see his soul
travel toward Heaven this is his first
step into overcoming the entities hold
on him even after Anna demands that
Sebastian rip off Claire's blindfold to
kill her he resists having an internal
struggle
soon Sebastian's treachery is revealed
and Claire finds out his glasses are
fake he can actually see through them
but with Father Esteban and his men hot
on their tails Claire will have to trust
Sebastian in order to escape they make
their way to the gondola where Sebastian
holds off the priest as Claire and
Sophia make their way up the tower all
this time Sebastian believed he was
responsible for the death of his
daughter but now he's come to the
realization that he was so overcome with
grief that it broke him grief can break
I thought it was chosen but it was just
broke even as the ghost of his dead
daughter leaps over the Flaming car to
get to Sebastian he does not budge this
is his chance at Redemption by Saving
Claire and Sophia it's one small step
towards mending the errors of his past
even Claire saving Sophia is an act of
redemption as Claire feels responsible
for leaving behind her mentally ill
brother Jack she won't leave Sophia
behind the gondola Tower itself is
surrounded by birds in fact bird imagery
can be seen throughout the film from
Anna's NightLight to birds tested at the
research facility by ringing this
massive Bell Claire alerts the soldiers
at the castle and must perfectly time
their jump into the gondola to make
their escape meanwhile Sebastian stabs
his daughter with his Steel Rod symbolic
of him finally letting go of her but
like most of her in this film it was a
figment of his imagination and the real
person he stabbed was none other than
the evil priest who with his last dying
strength plunges Sebastian into the rod
too the last we see of him he's staring
up to the sky at the birds above we
never actually see him die but his wound
seems pretty bad for him to pull through
meanwhile Claire and Sophia arrive at
the castle which indeed is a safe Refuge
it reminded me a lot of the ending to
the first bird box coming into this safe
place fresh produce are grown through
drapes in the sky and life seems to
thrive here as opposed to the
unforgiving streets below Sophia is
reunited with her mother who most
thought to be dead but before Claire can
join the group she must undergo some
tests the scientists here have devised a
DNA test to tell whether someone carries
the mutated Seer Gene and they believe
that this DNA could be the key to
creating immunity Claire also tells him
that it's possible to reach the Sears
and turn them back to normal she
witnessed this herself with Sebastian
these two new details open up a world of
possibility for future Bird Box movies
now it's important to note that the
events of this movie take place nine
months after the entities arrive while
the original has events that take place
five years after so we we can assume
that there is still no cure or solution
to this problem five years after the
entities arrive at least Bird Box
Barcelona leaves us with the possibility
of some sort of cure the final scene
gives us a glimpse into this testing we
have what is believed to be a Seer whose
blood is being synthesized and tested on
these rats according to the doctors this
is the 12th test with their last one
managing to hold off an entity for 48
seconds so I guess you could say they're
at least making progress inside the
containment room they have somehow
managed to capture an entity they never
explain how it was captured but that's a
question I would love to see answered in
any future installments of the franchise
but what did you think of bird box
Barcelona does it live up to its
predecessor I want to hear your thoughts
and theories below thanks for watching
be sure to like And subscribe and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory YT
until next time remember where are we
Barcelona
foreign